aerial backhanded sauce pass from heater watch out
one of the most exciting players in hockey Nathan
McKinnon he has it on side barely shot save by
Ben right out in the slot they don't want that to
happen with ranton and then drewan as McKinnon's
linemates causes so much Havoc does number 29
Nathan McKinny turnover shot SC holy snikes just
like that 123 in the Superstar Mo ranin gets his
28 goal of the Year something going on with them
they Lindy ruff's been asked about it and here
you you just watch Colorado go to work and this
is that Top Line we've talked a ton about Nathan
McKinnon but you know what Nico Ranon and and we
were talking about this before the game he doesn't
get as much credit it's Inspire Sam molinsky
in the lineup for Jack Johnson here's Nemitz
[Applause] shot not sure go or not but so
important for the to tie it up after the
raning goal 42 seconds later looks like Chris
Tierney is going to get the redirection bit of
an inexperienced goenda and and they go after
it they get in deep and you know what they've
been impressive twice so far they've been
in the middle of a change they've had one
for cheer hold off the uh the defenders
in Colorado Puck goes out high low to
high first game back since the break here comes
brat who 360 back just wi three defenseman out
there Gerard Taves and byro in the power play
very interesting look brat Breakaway from the
lead oh what a save by an in had him targeted
McKinnon in front Mar save rebound save still
loose where's the whistle there it is but card
denied another great a save by b ball keeps it
in on his toes around Sebastian in front
R off the side of the net wrap around oh
denied nemes But Here Comes Holtz 20-year-old
luk who standing Hugh standing up to him Holt
can shoot it saved by Anon in a big one Here
Comes Mercer Meyer can't handle in the high
slot and the crowd [Music] groans Here Comes
gold now kick save by vanich Manson shot score
what a snipe from Josh Manson his seventh goal
of the year 38 seconds into the second period
and Colorado has a 2-1 lead it was on the Zone
entry it was a little bit bobbled you can see
it's a quick trans position but they're trying to
figure out how to get this puff through and block
passes but they stay with it it wasn't smooth it
wasn't as easy as they like it and then what if
Manson steps in you mentioned a snipe doesn't
stick handle I talked about him before he has
been so good back there on we're used to seeing
kale marar score maybe even Deon Taves but good
for Josh man Manson to get them up by one by
the defenseman as he's entering the crease if
you watch right here as he's coming in there's
contact now the devil's defenseman initiate some
contact after the coaches challenge by New Jersey
it was determined there was goal interference no
goal yeah I think that's the right call because
at the end you also saw o Conor Marino fishes
it out reverses the Hughes goes up the wall
the car will for check but Pat calmly comes
out here comes Heir with brat chance for the
Devils brat SC oh that's [Applause] beautiful
the Double's leading score gets his 20th
goal of the year and the captain put it on
a team out there and he takes a pinch and he
does not succeed he thinks he's got the high
guy that's one thing ni ran talked about in
our interview with him they need that high
guy that F3 to be higher in the zone for
better support but they have to play catch
up so it's an odd man Rush another odd man
rush and this time jper bat makes them pay
what a good quick pass from niik Hees here too
what do you got a goal tender only a second
game this season with you guys what are you
seeing from usus Onin in he's looked pretty
good so far I mean you can't really fault him
for either one of those goals right they get
the one of the deflection and through his screen
and then that one's a pretty nice passing play
on the [Music] AR well that's not good for
anybody except Dawson Mercer Mercer makes
it 31 New Jersey look at the way that Colorado
likes to play they want the puck on their six
obviously every team wants it in the offensive
zone they're not doing a good job of protecting
the puck of managing the puck here and for New
Jersey they started this game slow they have
come alive they're hungry right now good job by
Eric Holla right there to get open get that puck
on he's a little off balance and then now the
doubles are set up up two to one on the power
play pass in front it's blose rebound another
save by out as it still loose no there's the
whistle quickly though comes the avalanch here's
Mar pressuring shot good stick by Luke H hit his
hand though he shakes it off and now has it
look out on the reverse and a goal kale Mard
stuck around the net picked up to lose change
deposits it in and it's a one-goal game in New
Jersey a quick pass from Devon Taves see this
is how they get in the zone and Taves is down
low they go up high this is watch this pass
Mar over to Devon Taves and then good read by
Taves and you look at all that space for ma he
stays with him he for checks he covers so much
ice we've talked about it and what you can see
there luk Hughes had no idea that he had somebody
coming around the net and it's artor linan who
gives Mar a GI four on four continues we knew
they had the advantage and they take advantage
yeah you know here's danan now pressuring need
to get a second win off this backto back situation
Duran's flying Gerard canc he's got room he's an
upore the ads have tied it up in 29 seconds just
his second goal goal of the Year Gerard has tied
the game well he had a ton of time to tee this
one up he picked the corner and he picked the
right one good work here good you know what you
mentioned drewan he goes out there we thought the
first four were going to have the advantage at
fouron four the marar the Daves the ranton and
the McKinnon but these guys are hungry they
go out there and Gerard all that time Van's
up on his angle but it's just a laser shot for
Gerard Marino the defenseman in Marino looking
around the front taken by Brad reron can't quite
get it here quick [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
shot John Marino the unexpected magic they
were looking for the fact that John Maro
jumps into the play right here on this Zone
entry not necessarily the defense when you'd
expect from that he does a good job and then
uses incap you just saw off to the side to
make sure that Anan cannot cover the Pu can't
freeze it right here you see brat he he keeps
it make sure that that puck stays alive and
look at Marino backs up recognizes he's he's
got the Kinnon on him there that little stop
that Marino makes back it's Lazar col Lazar
wins it but Duran anticipates gets it back
5 seconds ago good stick by Hala and he puts
it [Music]
this post allstar game push with a win
and it's it's a great face off they get
the puck out and then you know what at
this point they think the game over a
looks down goes for it good on him you
know that's harder to hit than it looks
like they only have four shots on
goal in the third but two went in